what is the highest percentage
submission in grappling overall you have
to go with the rare naked strangle
strangles from the back
if you look at most tournaments in most
rule sets
it has success across all rule sets
all weight divisions
all body types it doesn't require any
kind of specific physical advantage such
as height
in order to be effective
it works equally well in both fighting
and grappling
it will work regardless of how
physically and mentally tough your
opponent is okay a heel hook is a very
high percentage technique in in modern
day competition
but if your opponent simply makes up his
mind it is not going to tap and is
willing to take the physical damage
it won't result in the end of a match uh
a stranglehold by
contrast will always end the match
regardless of your opponent's mental
toughness
so um
i believe it's fair to say that at the
end of the day the single most high
percentage
method of uh submitting people and
grappling is a rare naked stream so when
you look at an athlete maybe gordon you
can speak to this like what what's the
best uh you mentioned gary with the
guillotine
what's the best submission to really
invest in is it the rear nicky choke
to really invest your development like
understanding the entirety of the system
that leads into that
i think that i mean you have to do them
all obviously but if i had like one
submission that i would only one
submission i could pick for the rest of
my life it would definitely be a rear
naked
can you explain maybe some of the actual
technical details of why that's the case
well
as john spoke about they're different in
joint locks whereas
you don't have to tap you can just let
your leg break and then keep going with
the strangle there's there's no uh
there's none of that um and then it's
just an inherent
advantage you have being behind someone
um whereas if you go for an arm bar you
stop you start from top mount and you're
facing the guy and then you put them
down and you're not directly behind them
with leg locks you're facing the guy
whereas when you're on someone's back
you have them in a pin where you can
your chest to back you have a body
triangle and you you're pinning the guy
in place you can't explode out he can't
grease his way out most of the time and
there's an inherent advantage you have
being behind them due to the fact that
we're poorly set up to deal with threats
behind us
so would you say that's the most
dominant position jiu jitsu like more
than mount
more than yeah side control more than i
think if you look at most matches
historically
most guys who get stuck in positions for
long amounts of time are guys that
they're back taken
if you get
an explosive guy from bottom mountain he
can bridge and he can off bound to you
and lock half guard maybe and then work
back to guard but someone locks a body
triangle on your back that's where you
see most guys getting pinned in place
for long amounts of time